so we've already been able to explore a
lot with our little thought experiment
where i am floating in space i'm at the
center of my frame of reference and
right at time equals zero in my frame of
reference a friend comes passing comes
in a spaceship passing me by with a
velocity v i'll say the magnitude is v
and it's going in the positive x
direction we're just going to focus and
we have been focusing just on the x
dimension for simplicity
and we've thought about reconciling
space and time in my frame of reference
relative to her frame of reference and
the conundrum that we faced in previous
videos is how do we reconcile that the
speed of light is always going to be the
same in every frame of reference and to
reconcile them we had to essentially
come up with the idea of space time and
i should say it even faster space time
space time let me write it out space
time and the first time i heard about
space time i assume that people were
just talking about space and time as
independent things and just plotting
your point in space and time but when
people talk about space-time they're
really talking about this continuum of
one thing and we're just talking about
different directions in space-time they
could have called this something else
they could have called the spime or
or or or taste or stace or
a lot of different things but this is
space-time and it's this idea that it's
this continuum and to and when we
started to make space-time diagrams we
realized in order for light the speed of
light to be absolute that time and space
weren't as independent of each other as
we thought and they weren't as absolute
as we thought and we constructed these
min minkowski space-time diagrams for
each of our frames of reference so my
frame of reference the space-time
diagram is here in white and for my
friend's
frame of reference her space-time
diagram is here in this blue color and
the angle formed between
these axises between the x and the x
prime axis and the ct and the ct
prime axis this angle alpha here this is
going to be dependent on her relative
velocity
relative in my frame of reference so in
my frame of
if her velocity is v or the magnitude of
velocity is v in my frame of reference
this angle we've already seen is going
to be the inverse tangent or the arc
tangent of the ratio between her
relative velocity and the speed of light
so this is going to be equal to the
inverse tangent
inverse tangent of v
over c so the faster she goes these two
things are going to start squeezing are
going to start squeezing together and if
somehow she would approach the speed of
light they would all they would both
approach a 45 degree angle and almost
and actually start to coincide if they
were actually able to approach the speed
of light and that's all interesting
already this idea that the space and
time are not as independent that's all a
continuum called space time but some of
you have probably said well i want to i
want to deal with some more tangible
numbers here for example
for example if this event right over
here in space time we can think about it
from my frame of reference and we could
think about it from her frame of
reference in my frame of reference i
would view the coordinates here
let's call this this coordinate would be
x
and this coordinate right over here
would be ct we had a whole video on why
we think of time in terms of ct the
units here literally would be meters we
could think of it as light meters if we
like so that would be the coordinates in
my frame of reference well what would be
the coordinates in her frame of
reference well we've we've already
thought about how to read these
minkowski space-time diagrams to find
her x-prime coordinate we would just go
parallel to the c t prime axis so that
would be the x prime coordinate in her
frame of reference and to figure out the
c t prime coordinate we would just go
parallel to the x prime axis
so this would be
this would be the c
t
prime coordinate now how do you actually
go in between transform from x to x
prime and from c t to c t prime and to
do that we're going to introduce in this
video
the lawrence transformations lawrence
lawrence transformations
transformations and what they do is they
allow us to do exactly what we just
needed to do allow us to go from
x
comma ct
to
to x prime
x prime
and c t prime
and to help us think about it i'm going
to introduce some variables and
hopefully it'll show the symmetry of the
lawrence transformations you might see
them written in other ways and in other
sources and we'll reconcile all of those
in the future but the lawrence
transformations we'll start with what we
call the lawrence factor because this
shows up a lot in the transformation so
i'll just define this ahead of time so
the lawrence fat the lorentz factor
denoted by the greek letter gamma
lowercase gamma it is equal to
1
over
the square root of 1 minus v squared
over c squared
now sometimes you might even see it
written
like well i'll write it another way
sometimes you might see it written as
gamma let me do that same color
same reddish color
gamma is equal to 1 over
the square root of 1 minus beta squared
and you might say well what is beta well
beta is another variable that shows up a
lot when we're thinking about special
relativity and beta is just
beta is just the ratio
beta is just the ratio between the
relative velocity her relative velocity
and my frame of reference and the speed
of light and it shows up a lot even this
angle alpha here we could have said this
is the inverse tangent
the inverse tangent of beta and it also
helps you this becomes a little bit
simpler when you write the lorentz
factor
and when we look at the actual
transformation between the coordinates
we'll see that beta becomes useful again
at least the way i like to write it so
if we want to think about what x prime
is going to be
so we can write
x prime
is going to be equal to the lawrence
factor
the lawrence let me do that red color
is going to be equal to
the lawrence factor
times
x
times x
minus
and now we're going to say beta
times ct
times
and c t prime
and c
t prime
is going to be equal to the lorentz
factor gamma let me do that same color
again
switching colors is sometimes difficult
gamma
times and we'll see it's just the other
way around it is going to be
it is going to be
c
let me do that green color
c t
c t minus you might even guess what i'm
about to write based on the the the
symmetry that we see here ct minus beta
beta
times x and i really want you to
appreciate this because this is it it
really shows that that space and time
are really are really just different
directions in the space time and there's
a nice symmetry to them right over here
notice we have
we have an x and we have an x
we have a
we have a c t and we have a c t so when
we're thinking about x prime it's x
minus beta times c t and we're and we're
scaling it by the lawrence factor and
then when we're thinking about time well
we do it the other way around we're
still scaled by the lawrence factor but
now it is ct minus beta times x now this
might all seem like greek to you and we
actually are using greek letters but in
the next video i'll actually use do some
sample numbers here and you'll see that
this is this evaluating these is just a
little bit of straightforward algebra